[Music]
the new Frasier series on Paramount plus
brings lots of new faces into Dr Crane's
life including a young mom with a tragic
backstory named Eve but where may you
have seen the actress who plays her
before the 2023 Frasier Revival shares a
name with its predecessor but its
setting and time frame set the new show
apart in plenty of key ways from the
classic '90s sitcom the most important
Edition is Frasier Crane's adult son
Freddy Frasier uproots himself to visit
and eventually live with his son in
Boston at the series start giving the
Revival an environment entirely distinct
from the iconic Seattle setting of the
original series at the start of the
first episode Freddy lives in an
apartment with a friend of his named Eve
Frasier initially assumes that Freddy
and Eve are in a relationship before
learning that Eve and her infant son
moved in with Freddy after the child's
father a firefighting colleague of
Freddy's died on the job I don't need to
be told who you are I wish I could say
the same Jess sgo plays Eve in the
Frasier Revival her filmography before
joining Frasier consists largely of
Television work including roles in shows
from the past decade that span a variety
of genres work and moms aired on the CBC
in sgro's home country of Canada between
2017 and 2023 Netflix carries the show
for international viewers as the title
implies it follows a group of mothers
attempting to overcome the Myriad
struggles of balancing an active career
with motherhood in an urban Toronto
setting Danny KES and Carlson is one of
these moms in season 1 Ann decides that
her daughter Alice might benefit from
some discipline and hires a young woman
with a Stern demeanor played by sgo to
babysit the character takes on the
nickname mean nanny mean Nanny yeah
that's what we call you mean Nanny H I
don't care I kind of like it but she and
Alice end up getting along undermining
Anne's plan mean Nanny continues working
for an and becomes a recurring character
through seasons 2 and three her
storyline reaches its dramatic Apex when
Annie's best friend Kate finds out that
her husband Nathan is having an affair
with me Nanny near the end of season 2
this affair understandably leads to me
Nanny's departure from the series Ziro
plays the character in a total of 12
episodes Canadian sitcom letter Kenny
takes place in the fictional Canadian
small town of the title frequently
causing drama in the town of Letterkenny
are its hockey teams including both the
letter Kenny Shamrocks and the letter
Kenny Irish three of the show's core
cast members Riley Jonesy and shy play
for both of these teams at various
points in the show season 5 introduces a
women's hockey team called the letter
Kenny shamrocket throughout the team's
periodic appearances its two key players
are bettyanne played by Kelly McCormick
and Maran played by sgo in a May 2020
interview with popternative sgo said
that she and McCormick had such a good
time on the letter Kenny set that she
left sore one day as a result of nearly
laughing during filming referring to
chirping the show's term for ribbing or
mocking she said I remember leaving set
one day I think probably our first time
we ever did it which was this locker
room scene where bettyanne and I are
chirping each other out we left that day
and I'm like man I have the worst chest
pains and I was like what is this oh
it's holding in laughter it's literally
from me trying so hard not to laugh who
would have thought the girl who ingested
mosquito eggs after drinking out of mud
puddles would ever almost be accepted to
Community College in the first episode
of the satirical superhero show the boys
protagonist huy Campbell's partner Robin
Ward played by salgo dies after flash
parody a train collides with her at a
high speed killing her instantly after
her death Robin retains a presence in a
few more episodes in season 1 huie is so
upset by her death that he joins Billy
butcher as a member of the boys
organization which is devoted to
stopping the world's overpowered and
egotistical superheroes while he's still
coming to terms with losing her huie is
haunted by visions of Robin particularly
after starting up a new relationship
with Starlight before long though
Starlight helps him move on sgo shared
some insight into her brief but
impactful time working on the boys in a
September 2019 interview with kider I
had a spidey sense when I was reading
these scripts I was I hadn't felt that
way about anything I'd read the expanse
aired on sci-fi for three seasons before
its cancellation and subsequent return
as an Amazon Original Series in the
first Prime video season of the expense
sgo debuted as Shandra way who has an
Amorous entanglement with Amos Burton
complicating their interactions is her
Devotion to her boss Adolphus mytree who
she credits with saving her life Shandra
is relatively kind-hearted but Mery is
outright evil so while sgo maintains a
central role throughout season 4 as a
member of its main cast her character's
association with the villainous mercher
culminates with Amos having to kill her
concluding her run on the series sgo
told the Fearless Nomad in July 2022 I
loved playing Shandra away on the
expanse I loved the complexity with
which she was written when something is
written well I find that the character
sticks with me and is sometimes
incorporated into who I am she's one of
those in 2020 Netflix adapted the novel
tiny pretty things into an original TV
series the first and only season of
which hit the streaming service in
December of that year it's mostly set at
The Archers School of Ballet in Chicago
which trains Elite dancers but hides
some Insidious secrets sgo plays
Isabelle a former Soldier working as a
Chicago cop she's tasked with
investigating the case of Cassie Shaw a
top dancer whose fall from the school
roof is ruled an accident but which
Isabelle suspects was the result of Foul
Play sgo said of Isabelle in a May 2021
interview yeah she had a hard go of it
for sure she was a dark uh character she
also mentioned that she filmed a brief
role in the Netflix superhero drama
Jupiter's Legacy at the same time
between then and the Fraser reboot sgo
also worked on including why the last
man and Sip and did Voice work for the
2021 video game Far Cry